this is a production of Cornell
University
hi welcome to the Cornell turfgrass
video log we here at the bethpage State
Park in early June and one of the things
we're starting to notice on the greens
and I think we're noticing this all over
northern climates is we've come through
some heat and then some cool weather the
spring growth surge is just about behind
us now and it's about time that the two
grass systems we managed on putting
greens start to react a little
differently you'll notice we've got a
much more in starting to get an increase
in bank grass as the heat is coming on
and it's starting to get a little bit
leggy so that may need some additional
cultural practices topdressing vertical
morning but you've got to be really
careful because if you start to do that
aggressively the annual bluegrass which
will not like the heat will not take it
as well and you could set yourself up
for additional problems especially as
we're approaching the summer equinox and
we get to that climatological maximum ET
where sons highest in the sky and we're
losing them about a two tenths of an
inch of water a day we'll have to really
keep track of our stressful practices
while the bent grass might need it the
annual bluegrass might suffer from some
damage if you try to be too aggressive
so try to find that sweet spot and
getting that bent grass managed to
provide a good putting surface without
adding additional problems to the annual
bluegrass this is Frank grassi for the
Cornell turfgrass video log this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu